okay for people joining this live stream
our second design review of the day
um uh we are looking at
interactive graphics in the cloud
and this looks a little horrifying here
so help me understand what i'm seeing
okay so there's a little bit of you know
stuff just to set
up um so there's sort of the underlying
cloud implementation that john and his
uh team have been working on um
and then i think the more interesting
thing is
sort of how do we expose that in sort of
the normal wolfram language
and so if you evaluate the
initialization section there
so i can only run this in the cloud
right now at the moment yes i mean some
of the stuff would be
relatively straightforward to do it i
just did i just
evaluated that initial that group of
initialization cells and nothing
happened
so what's going on here i'm just
pressing shift enter on this
nothing's happening oh it's read only
it's it's just a second um can you is it
possible for him to make a local copy of
a copy of it for his own use
well nobody tried this i assume
or maybe everybody just immediately
grabbed their own
what should i do to make this
evaluatable
go to file
duplicate
where's duplicate
could not be duplicated okay so change
the permissions please
yep i'll do that right now
that's dot wolfen
right you have it brett
yes i am
i'll stop wolfe from oven.com i see
that's what i just told you yeah so i
was seeing if i could do it just for
everybody
um okay
okay shift enter shift return rather
read only okay this meter
has a claim
has to close the notebook
uh close the notebook okay i have closed
the notebook
that looks better
now the fact that it gave me no
indication of why
i couldn't evaluate it seems wrong
previously am i making sense beyond
yeah i agree it's that read-only but
it's not obvious why you couldn't
evaluate yeah
there's small gray text at the top right
all right so it should put up a notifier
when you try and do shift enter it your
prep and notifier saying can't evaluate
it's
yep okay and you already talked about
some other changes like
it could also suggest you to make a
duplicate when you click
read only or yeah yeah absolutely
okay so here why didn't those turn other
than blue
probably because they're in a in a
context
but that's wrong in terms of the
coloring conventions
yeah that needs to be looked into
okay okay
all right what am i doing here okay so
go ahead and evaluate that definition
the options and the thing okay
and so this is a highlight set
interaction okay
which is working at the moment by
changing you know by basically by
magnifying
the content okay so so
let's understand the base concepts here
the base concepts are highlightable
right yes so this is this is like
um
oh something like highlight graph
is sort of a model for this where
it defines a static piece of
highlighting
right so this is
instead
so the intention is that you are going
to quickly
implement these same things for the
desktop right
right i mean some of the stuff is easily
implementable in desktop and some of it
is
you know less
implementable um the one we're looking
at right now
how you do on desktop
right
um
i think highlighting might be a good
good term so you'd say highlighting
and there's a default
um and then you'd give a second argument
which could have some theme names
just type of highlights right
um
[Music]
well this is nice
okay why doesn't this work um
oh because i've left one where only one
of the data sets was highlighted
highlighting highlighted we don't want
highlighted because that suggests it's
always highlighted
and highlighted is already a thing
what is it it draws something with a
yellow background or something
wait a minute so it's not consistent
with this
it's also a static thing it's not it's
not on i understand but
but if i take this
and i say and here
i have no idea what that's going to do
well what is this what is it well
take out the and that was something you
had i think nick
implement you know so if you do
highlighted of a string
you know it's
well i mean you have the document button
right there so yeah i know i like to
just see it yeah
well i like this
i forgot we had this this is nice
right i mean but that's geared toward
textual things
but we could also do the same thing
in graphics we could reuse this wrapper
for static highlighted things in
graphics in other words that would be a
useful thing just like we have highlight
graph
we could have a wrapper that says
highlighted that does one of these
highlighting actions
statically so what i'm saying
so then what we'd have is highlighted
and then we'd have highlighting
and highlighting would be the dynamic
action and highlighted would be
i just want this you know like i want
you know i'm gonna want this
basically whoops wherever that was with
just the blue
you know if i say highlighted of those
points that would be a very convenient
thing to be able to do
do you see what i'm saying okay so
that's what i think we should do i think
we should have highlighting
that specifies the dynamic version and
highlighted that specifies the
you know the version that's already been
um
how can we not have graphics as a
whatever i'm gonna put it in
visualization okay andrea
okay yeah yeah oh i mean i assume you're
paying attention so i
am i am so i know where the notebook is
so i can send it later
okay right so change this to
highlighting and i think we've got a
winner here
now let's start looking at your drop
lines and so on
um
and that style of drop lines is
i haven't come up with a desktop
implementation that's
nearly as nice and smooth as this
well we may have to have a low-level
implementation of this yeah
i don't call it a drop line when it goes
horizontally
what else are these called fiducial
lines or something what are they called
um i mean i'd normally think of them as
drop lines
no matter what direction they're going
um
[Music]
this is what we implemented in waltham
alpha like 10 years ago
right and you know so you can also
like i have a function a little bit
further down which does just the drop
lines which i called crosshairs
which you know possibly we don't want
for political reasons or something
um i don't i wouldn't worry about that
every every word is used for something
at some time yeah all right
um
um okay
i'm not believing in that yet but but
but i mean the next okay so the next
category
is drop lines
or aka crosshairs
aka tether i don't believe what about
well okay so this functionality though
right so that one's tied to the data
well so is this yeah yeah but like the
wolfram alpha
ones are just completely free form
right i mean you could put your mouse in
the top left corner of that plot
on you know the alpha one and it would
still draw
the lines
this is what i mean
muck i don't know how to read our
name from the live stream is suggesting
no i don't think we have to worry about
getting confused between highlighted and
highlighting because they're going to do
the same thing
on on points highlighted is just the
static version of highlighting
in this case i mean this arguably
highlighting
should work dynamically for expressions
you see what i'm saying
if you say highlighting for this
expression it should do this
at what level at the level it wraps
around
right so so this highlight okay
i i thought maybe you meant that
highlighting of range of 10 should you
know
highlight five when you move over it
no i'm suggesting that highlighting
should look here if i say
you know um if i say you know
by the way i don't know why we don't
give this example but
i'm not cute right but there
we should give that example by the way
in in um
uh could somebody um andrea can you
please put that example get that example
in an application section for
highlighted
okay
um and if that isn't in the application
section
framed it is exactly this is in the
application section of framed
right so we should just have that also
for highlighted
okay um could you put yourself on mute
so we're not here and typing
um
okay so we need to specify what possible
highlighting
options there are but we're going to
come to that in a minute this is clearly
a different concept this drop lines
thing in my opinion is a different
concept i mean maybe you can get that by
some setting
in highlighting but i'm not sure i think
it's a different concept
okay okay how many more concepts are
there here
at the moment just one um
okay so crosshairs i see crosshairs is
an
un is that's an overall graphics feature
that has nothing to do with the data
right
okay so that's a setting okay so
okay so these are global settings
so one issue is that we need a way to
say highlight
everything that is highlight each
individual point wants to be highlighted
right in here do you understand what i'm
saying
so we have highlight set and we have
highlight point which is
a little bit further below it no but
that's not the right design because what
you want to know
i'm not saying well yeah okay i'm just
saying is an example of i think where
you're going
i don't you know that's that's that's
within each um
you're saying within each set
you know it's like a list highlighting
or something yeah
i mean that's a that is really almost
like
oops crazy um
oops it did record that um
okay so highlighted applies to a
complete lump of stuff
highlighted is the static one i know
but it also applies to a whole
everything that is inside it because it
doesn't have anything else to do
um
okay highlighting list highlighting each
now i mean there's also the question of
to what extent we just make this be a
default
you know i don't really see any reason
why this shouldn't be a default thing
for points
to highlight like that
do we have anybody from ux so do we get
noah or somebody here
we do not have no i don't think um
because that would be related to the
drawing tools but i don't see why we
shouldn't just have this work
you know why it shouldn't and what harm
could it possibly do to have this
highlighting work
for every point
do you understand what i'm saying um
i don't know how you do that in the
desktop and i suspect that we'll need
low level support to make that work
i mean on desktop it would be you know
currently a heavy
operation right but so so we need to we
need to fix that right
right why is there a delay
in this case that's called goofy
is there a delay in this case i saw that
the one blue point on the left stayed
yeah i'm not sure but i did see that i
mean i'm wondering if
it's you know there's some timer that is
wrong it's a bug okay
so i have to say
my tendency is to say it should just do
this by default
and that the highlighting list thing
that there should be a global setting
um you know um
more or less and include highlighting
or default highlighting
do you want that default behavior for
all points and graphics or do you want
it more as a
default behavior for more charting level
stuff
right like list i understand stuff like
that yeah
i understand the question i suspect we
shouldn't do it for graphics because i
suspect that in graphics
in raw graphics you could have used
points to build things
and you don't want the individual so
include highlighting
include highlighting would be set to
false by default
in graphics
[Music]
um
so that would be like you know the list
plot family and
probably plots or something would true
for charting
um it should not be set for the epilogue
right a prologue in epilogue right you
understand
um okay so let's go down here
okay so this is disembodied crosshairs
so i don't know whether this is the
right we'll have to think about this but
i mean include crosshairs
it is a lowercase h for crosshairs isn't
it
i believe so i think so
i mean obviously i think so but
yeah okay i think so too okay
it's a concern about performance with
highlighting i i
i mean we're only going to do this this
this this performance is not a problem
right this
this performance is is going to work i
mean
that works you know fine on desktop you
know
fine on cloud i don't know what this
thing is
the crosshairs i mean yes no no this
this thing here
is not a performance issue if you have a
very large number of points there's no
performance hit associated with making
this highlighting work is that a correct
statement
there's going to be a some slight but
it's uh
it's like log n data structures it's
good
well because of the hip testing
yeah the hit testing is using kd trees
for this so it's
okay it should be uh well but i mean
it's
something we we yeah we should be a
little careful about that we should
obviously measure that
i mean there's some other hit because
it's also increasing
the size of the the nested hierarchy of
the svg but
we've talked about this before having
uh if we really want to we need a
definite answer here we need to not
just sort of hope that this is going to
be okay all right john
that that's a mistake you make too often
okay
let's let's not hope right let's let's
decide we're going to have you are
basically telling me
as the number of points increases the
size of the data structure increases
right by substantially is that right
it's not like let n it's like
n log n is that correct
uh i think it's login lookup for
no no no the size of the data structure
you just are the same
data structure the size of the data
structure is just the number of points
the lookup time is no that's not true
the kd tree that you maintain
has n log n size
right you've got to maintain the tree
think about it
all right where is the tree john can you
answer that question
the trees uh javascript data structure
that we build up
right how big is that data structure
it's an n-log thank you that's what i
was saying
okay so how big i mean that will get big
right so is it the case
in fact that we need to have some kind
of automatic here or something some cut
off
do you understand the question yes i
understand the question uh
i mean i think it's not a bad idea to
have it automatic and
yeah i mean because you know over a
thousand
points or something is just going to be
a dense blob and
well still it's going to be interesting
to see
particularly if there are different
colors of points and so on
now
okay according to wikipedia the
kdtree spaces order n and searches login
no no the kd
tree has to maintain its
data structure
think about it
do you got to know which which section
i think at least let me think about this
for a second well
okay you you guys just need to get a
straight answer to this
no think about it it's got to maintain
the information about which tree
that's got to maintain the pointer
structure that shows which
side of the tree you're on given a
particular value
anyway never mind
yeah that's an interesting issue fade
the non-selected set
yes we should have these in plot themes
okay all right
well so the issue is we've got two cases
here we've got the case where you put
an individual highlight around every
element
and we've got the case i don't think we
need to have a separate wrapper for that
for
the time being i think we should just
call it highlighting and if you want it
around every point you put it around
every point
and
then we have the global thing okay so
this one
we have the global thing here
um okay so we've got highlighting
okay so the second argument to
highlighting
could be the the arguments are
um expand
we might have brighton or we might have
something like um
uh expand outline that would be some
kind of yellow outline
to follow this highlighting scheme okay
what i'm saying
um and then we also want
um
dim other i don't know that sounds
somewhat like some kind of
chinese food thingy
right i mean in highlight image that's
you know that's effectively done as a
third argument
you know that's sort of a background i
see okay
okay so highlight
well let's look at highlight image what
is it how does it do this
right i mean so we have highlight image
highlight graph and highlight mesh
and there's you know some differences
between all of them
that's a good design i think to have a
background style there
forego and style and background style
that's sensible
now what concerns me a little bit
[Music]
is that you might want a dynamic version
of this for images how would you do that
do you see what i'm saying right i mean
you
sort of have to have some sort of
dynamic region of interest
you know a disc or something that you're
able to move around
a lens right i think you should talk to
the the image processing team about this
um
okay
all right now i still need to name this
one
here so crosshair isn't the same thing
because that's
and include crosshairs that's a global
setting for the graphic
right
is that the right term include
crosshairs
i mean axes goes to it it might just be
cross hairs goes too
maybe um i think it'd be better to say
include gossip because that way we can
have a potentially
a future crosshairs wrapper
right
now if we think we're by default going
um you know we could instead have drop
lines be called here
crosshairs and then
of object
and then we could say
vertical horizontal whatever
or we could say x y whatever zero could
be true false or
you know just b
yeah we could say this comma x or
something we could
allow several different possibilities
but i think that's probably the right
way to do it and if you want cross has
you know crosshairs on a list of objects
would just put crosshairs on each
individual one
you know clearly cross says only do
anything
what what what the difference though is
that that would
be
that that's not it where's the one
further up
that one's dead in the water
oh i see that's only the primes
okay so if i wanted to we're still
talking about you know if i wanted
one of these to light up but not the
other i just think that's a weird and
unusual case
and i think you could oh god whatever
hello
any idea why that's happening
i've spent hundreds of hours mousing
over these plots i've never seen that
because there's a
it's really a weird business i you know
and i have 20 years of experience
with that what
with your ability to yeah right find
these things
it's crazy it's crazy i you know
and it's always the first thing you try
it's yes i know
it's just um
okay so
okay so let's just review this again for
a second so again i don't think this is
useful
to have a individual point but we could
do that
again we can always do that by just
putting highlighting on individual
points right
you know what i got an idea in here
we could say uh separate
or something
we could say in this we could have
something which says for example we
could say
um you know the default could be
all arrow expand you see what i'm saying
and the other one could be
you know something like individual arrow
expand
or we could also have just expand
we could say here individual expand
individual outline
you see what i'm saying
now we're also going to have to give
styles for the highlighting
um well i guess these are these are the
named styles but what we're doing here
is in general the thing would be in the
in the product at least
and we won't support this as a function
that you apply to the graphics primitive
right
do you understand what i'm saying that
returns whatever it does
right and it can be a function that is
either given a list or it's given an
individual primitive
did you see what i'm saying i i see what
you're saying i don't
and i mean so so that makes it i mean so
it has a callback
yeah so we're not going to support this
initially
but this is a kind of design direction
there's a conceptual design
it applies a function to the primitive
okay i think this is reasonable do
people like this
i i like that and um
and you know we can do you know a list
form of those
that you know either does multiple
things and or
allows you to specify a parameter
fine um
in large outline we could say something
like
recolor
or style or
well you're saying that
in here you could just give a style
specification
well i was saying like string style and
then
comma red or something style arrow red
and we could say then something like
enlarge
style arrow red right i mean
actually can you go back to the docs for
like highlight image
because they have a way for this that's
style specification
right so we don't have a region of
interest it's
you know that's what the image is
right i mean because right so you could
you're saying you just throw the style
right in there without style arrow
just say red right in there as well as
in large you could just say this
yeah maybe something like that that's
fine i think that's just fine to be able
to do that
wouldn't it make more sense to keep the
individual versus
all as a as an orthogonal
option or is it a concept
yes it would
well so we've got three things here
we've got
we've got three issues we've got
um individual behavior
whole object behavior
and background behavior
right so maybe what we should do
is this isn't quite right but something
more like you know whole
arrow whatever individual arrow whatever
background error whatever
actually it isn't even background it's
really other objects right
right
i mean that's the most general case what
to do with the whole thing because you
could imagine doing both things you
could imagine both highlighting an
individual point
and highlighting the overall cut you
know this thing and
all points you could do something with
here right
they all get bigger but the one you're
over turns red
yes for example
mark on our live stream is asking about
highlighting with certain
conditions that's the whole point this
is all you can specify whatever you want
symbolically this is just the the end
result of doing that
you can you can write code that will
highlight whatever you want
um this is just the actual wrapper that
determines the highlighting
um
i'm gonna have to go in a moment here um
i'm glad to see this finally working
okay
[Music]
um
okay all right let's just look at this
one more time here
um
i kind of need to go um
can you guys think this through a little
bit more and come back yeah sure
another version of this i mean i think
you're very close here
and i'm really happy to see this finally
work well done
too soon yeah matt did a lot of work on
this yeah
um
and uh i assume that other kinds of
charting will just
work i mean it'll take you know a little
bit to hook it up
you know i mean obviously this you know
applies to
like the edge forms that highlight on
barge and bar chart and whatnot
um i see so you have to hook all that
stuff up
right i mean it's not a lot of work
you know so i mean geo region value plot
will it just work for that
i'm not sure
i haven't looked at what this does on
like polygons recently
okay um oh look bob just asked the exact
same question
on our live stream okay yep
okay let's just look at this for one one
more second here
i think that we what we should do is
make highlighting by default
just be a whole second argument just be
whole whatever the whole thing is
the
but um
[Music]
then allow this association
because this
um i i kind of think there may be other
choices here
to remember i mean i suspect so um but
and
likely actually flexible light up and
you know who knows what else
right lighting up a dot on the axis et
cetera et cetera
great so i think this is the right thing
to do highlighting by default just takes
a thing that refers to the whole object
you can always get it symbolically you
can just
apply to fewer objects or you do this
okay why don't you guys just try and try
and make this work and then
here we could support either x or y or x
y
or list true false and so on and
obviously in 3d we're going to want to
see crosshairs in 3d that will be more
interesting
possibly harder yes it will be harder
well i mean the obvious problem with 3d
is that the i know the point is only in
2d
yes and so basically what you have to do
is the crosshairs have to light up
when something in the uh xy
projection when you hit a point in the
xy projection
then you light up you know then you do
the crosshairs to all the axes
right which is the most useful thing
um all right good stuff for those paying
attention to the live stream we have
another live stream about 30 minutes
completely different kind
brainstorming experimental tests of our
physics models
um all right anyway good stuff
i'd like to see this again please make
sure we you know
do the things to merge with highlighted
and things
okay sounds good see you guys soon
see ya